JAMES GRIME: Well, we're going
to talk about illegal numbers.
And when I heard that there
were these things, illegal
numbers, that some numbers were
illegal, I was shocked
and surprised as well.
Today, in the modern world,
numbers are used as keys to
encrypt secret information.
They're used to encrypt or
protect DVDs as well, so that
you can't illegally copy
films off a DVD.
You need to protect
those keys.
So if you distribute those
secret keys, those secret
numbers, this is
a real problem.
And some people are claiming
that it would be illegal to
distribute those numbers.
And so it's the number itself
that becomes illegal.
And there are some other
problems as well because you
can consider a digital
photograph or a computer
program as simply as a string
of binary digits.
And then a string of binary
digits is a number.
So there is a number
for a photograph
or a computer program.
So if you distribute the number,
you could sort of work
out the original computer
program or the image.
And if that's an illegal
computer program that's
hacking data, then does the
number become illegal itself?
To show you the problem, I
thought, I don't want to write
down any illegal numbers
in this video.
So I thought I'd come up
with my own example.
So imagine if we decide
to trademark the name
Numberphile.
So we're going to write down
Numberphile first of all.
I'm going to use capital letters
because I like the
number we got at
the end better.
So I'm going to use capital
letters for Numberphile.
I've written out the
word Numberphile.
Now, each character in ASCII has
a binary representation.
So let's do that.
So for the capital
N, 01001110.
And now I can do it up
for the U as well.
But I'd better get them right.
You know they'll notice.
The H, 0101.
Whoo.
So that's Numberphile written
as a binary string.
So if we joined all that
together, that's just one big
binary number.
Do you want to know what
that number is?
So that number in
decimal is 94--
040--
177.
So this is Numberphile
written as a number,
the Numberphile number.
And if I catch any of you
distributing this number about
on the internet, right, you're
infringing our trademark, OK?
Don't let me catch
you doing that.
There is a serious problem.
So I'm a mathematician,
not a lawyer.
I can't talk about the full
implications of this.
I'm hoping that I am giving
you the extreme case, a
simplified extreme case.
But at the very least, this is
what we're trying to avoid,
that numbers themselves
become illegal.
That's what we're trying to
avoid because the implications
of it are bizarre.
So you can't distribute
these illegal numbers.
But then can you distribute
the number minus 1?
Or if I write down a list of
numbers where some of them are
illegal, am I allowed to
distribute that list?
I hope that it's distributing
the number and the intent to
infringe copyright.
But the extreme case is what
we're trying to avoid.
It has become a problem.
In recent years, there have been
a couple of cases where
people like Sony have sued
people for distributing their
secret encryption keys for
their PlayStation 3.
And the Motion Picture
Association of America have
forced people to remove posts
that were encryption keys for
their DVDs, which people were
using to illegally copy DVDs.
This annoyed the internet.
Ah, the internet-- this
annoyed them.
So then they started to
taunt these people.
So what they started
to do next is they
would take these numbers.
And to taunt, they would then
turn these numbers into
hexadecimal.
And hexadecimal defines
colors as well.
So then they become
illegal colors.
If I do this for Numberphile--
I've worked this out already.
This number, which is 94
septillion and something, if I
write it in hexadecimal--
5D--
4, 2--
42, 4, 5--
so this is the Numberphile
number written as hexadecimal.
Now, these groups here
define a color.
Each of those groups define a
color, and then we've got a
little bit extra.
So what you can do then is you
can make something like this.
So these are the three colors
defined by the Numberphile
number plus that little
extra bit.
And then if you start posting
this around on internet
forums, again, you'll be
infringing our trademark, and
we'll be round to come
round your house.
And we're going to stamp on
all your favorite toys.
So I don't want to catch
any of you doing that.
BRADY HARAN: So here are some
of those taunting protests
that James referred
to in the video.
These are colored flags based
on the DVD and PlayStation
encoding numbers.
Of course, another issue we
didn't touch on this video
surrounds copyrighting
of numbers like pi.
And there's a lot of stories
involving that, too.
Maybe we'll talk about
that another time.
A quick thanks to James Clewett,
who actually turned
the Mona Lisa into zeros
and ones for me.
And if you'd like to read more
about that, I'll put a link in
the video description.
And lastly, because we're a
lot more relaxed about our
illegal numbers here at
Numberphile, James Grime and I
have put that piece of paper
used in the video on eBay in
case anyone wants to get
their hands on it.
Again, links in the
video description.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll be back with
more videos soon.